today on the matt walsh show big pharma
has millions of people hooked on
antidepressants but a bombshell new
study reveals that everything they told
us about the drugs is false this is just
the latest big pharma scam to be exposed
we'll talk about it also speaking of big
pharma fails joe biden has been
vaccinated three times and yet still
contracted covet this was announced a
day after the president seemed to say
that he has cancer what's that all about
plus aoc tries to defend herself against
the charge that she faked being in
handcuffs and dave chappelle's upcoming
show is moved to a different venue after
trans activists complained in our daily
cancellation a lesbian bar in portland
falls victim to the woke mob in
hilarious fashion all of that and more
today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
well roe v wade has been overturned and
this battle is now finally leaving dc
and going to the grassroots and no group
in america when it comes to grassroots
is better positioned to fight this
battle than 40 days for life there are 1
million volunteers hold peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities in a
thousand cities in fact most of their
volunteers are located in blue states
such as california where the lives of
innocent babies are the most threatened
and will continue to be uh very much
threatened even after overweight is
overturned many former abortion facility
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no-show rate to
increase to as high as 75 which is a
major blow for the abortion business
these peaceful vigils have even led to
many closures of abortion facilities in
america nearly uh half of which were in
states like san francisco or cities like
san francisco chicago and seattle hardly
pro-life areas 40 days for life is
effectively changing hearts and minds in
the grassroots to end abortion so check
out their locations podcasts and free
magazines at
40daysforlife.com because again even
with roofy weight overturned this fight
for uh for life is not over in fact it
kicks into a new gear
and uh in many states you know babies
will be even more threatened than they
were before so we have to keep on top of
this and that's why you should be
supporting groups like 40 days for life
for more information on 40 days for life
simply head to 40daysforlife.com
if you've been uh listening to the show
for a while you know that i have been a
long time skeptic of the pharmaceutical
industry now of course pretty much
everyone claims to be a skeptic of the
pharmaceutical industry people on the
left are predisposed you would think
anyway to hate big pharma because it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
which you can put the word big in front
of and that means that it's evil many
people on the right have become even
more critical of big pharma in the last
few years especially because of how it
has pushed the covert vaccines a push
that now by the way as of a few weeks
ago
officially includes children as young as
six months old so if you want to bring
your baby in for a covet vaccine you can
now do that though i certainly wouldn't
recommend it and yet
a large preponderance of both groups
even while usually assuming a kind of
skeptical posture towards this industry
will let big pharma entirely off the
hook
when it comes to psychiatric drugs
as of 2021 nearly 65 million americans
had been prescribed at least one
psychiatric drug think about that for a
second 65 million americans
just five years before that the number
was 40 million 40 million was already
sky high
in five years it's gone up over 20
million
20 percent of the country is on
medication for mental illness and that
number is climbing by multiple
percentage points every year meanwhile
our our health authorities our so-called
health authorities tell us that the real
crisis is untreated read
non-drugged unprescribed mental illness
so they see the 65 million americans on
psychotropic drugs for mental illness
and they insist that the number is far
too low we actually need to get it much
higher should be 100 million should be
150 it should be everybody
they and i'm not joking about that
either because the dsm expands the
diagnostical manual of mental disorders
expands with each new addition
until every single human emotion
personality trait uh proclivity impulse
has become
a mental illness and we're already at
the point with the latest dsm where you
can open it up and find probably at
least five or ten mental illnesses that
would apply to you
so
they
the health establishment the medical
establishment they demand that uh that
more and more mentally ill quote unquote
people most of them suffering from
things like depression or anxiety or
adhd be identified and drugged
immediately
never mind the significant and often
dangerous side effects of these drugs
never mind that we're altering people's
brains and mass
never mind that we're diagnosing
conditions that we barely understand and
drugging them based on poorly supported
and sometimes demonstrably false medical
theories never mind all that
just keep the drugs and most importantly
the money flowing
this is what big pharma along with
doctors and psychiatrists have been
doing
and many people on both the left and
right who are normally quite eager to
criticize the medical establishment fall
silent
as that same medical establishment
declares millions upon millions of
americans
mentally ill so mentally ill that they
need psychotropic drugs in order to
function
on this point
many of our big pharma critics are
willing to simply take big pharma's word
for it well they say we're all mentally
ill so i guess we are
they might lie about everything else
these uh selective critics will say but
they would never lie about the best
treatment for depression well they would
never lie about that
quite an odd claim when you think about
it
and on the subject of depression uh the
quote mental illness that accounts for a
large portion of that 65 million figure
it's been taken as gospel for many years
that drugs are necessary to treat it
because
the condition is caused by a
quote-unquote chemical imbalance in the
brain
this is an idea that people have
absorbed from the culture and especially
from propaganda from the drug companies
you know it's not it didn't it this
didn't end up out there by accident
that's what the drug companies want you
to believe
it's a chemical imbalance so we'll give
you a little chemical and a pill and fix
it right up for you
and it's a doctrine that is jealously
guarded and defended
i know from experience that if you
question it
if you dare suggest
that maybe there's more to it than a
chemical imbalance you will be viciously
attacked for your heresy
people like the chemical imbalance idea
because it seems simple and because it
totally absolves the individual from the
responsibility to do anything to help
solve their own mental troubles it takes
things like you know lifestyle diet etc
takes that out of the equation entirely
it gives a simple cause promises a
simple solution and one that requires
almost no work on the part of the
individual just take the pill that's it
take the pill and everything will be
better
that's big pharma's motto take the pill
take the shot everything will be fine
you solve your depression with a magic
pill big pharma makes billions win-win
for everybody right
well wrong
the problem with the chemical imbalance
idea
the one that has led to millions of
people being put on psychiatric drugs
the one that has put billions and
billions hundreds of billions into the
pockets of big pharma the problem with
that idea
is that there was never any evidence to
support it it's a marketing slogan it's
not a medical diagnosis
and a study that was just released this
week this is a truly i don't use this
phrase very often in a non-ironic way
but it is a bombshell study reported by
the guardian
finally blows the lid off of the whole
scam here's the headline
little evidence that chemical imbalance
causes depression ucl scientists find
reading now from the study it says
scientists have called into question the
widespread use of antidepressants after
a major review found no clear evidence
that low serotonin levels are
responsible for depression
prescriptions for antidepressants have
risen dramatically since the 1990s with
one in six adults and two percent of
teenagers in england now being
prescribed them millions more people
around the world regularly use
antidepressants quote many people take
antipress antidepressants because
they've been led to believe their
depression has a biochemical cause but
this new research suggests that this
belief is not grounded in evidence this
according to the study's lead author
joanne moncrief a professor of
psychiatry university college london and
consultant psychiatrist at northeast
london nhs foundation trust quoted is
always difficult to prove a negative but
i think we can safely say that after a
vast amount of research conducted over
several decades there is no convincing
evidence that depression is caused by
serotonin abnormalities particularly by
lower levels or reduced activity of
serotonin thousands of people suffer
from side effects of antidepressants
including the severe withdrawal effects
that can occur when people try to stop
them top stop taking them yet
prescription rates continue to rise we
believe this situation has been driven
partly by the false belief
that depression is due to a chemical
imbalance it is high time to inform the
public that this belief is not grounded
in science
so it would seem that big pharma has
made billions of dollars fixing a
problem that does not exist
depression certainly exists don't get me
wrong
but depression caused by a chemical
imbalance is a myth
and it is a mythical creation
that the antidepressants are meant to
fix
it's something the pharmaceutical
companies have made up a problem they
made up and then
gave us the cure for reading more from
this report which is uh just more and
more damning for the pharmaceutical
industry as you go along
it says in the new analysis researchers
said 85 to 90 of the public believes
depression is caused by low serotonin or
a chemical imbalance most
antidepressants are selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors originally said to
work by corrupt correcting abnormally
low serotonin levels
the review published in the journal
molecular psychiatry looked at studies
examining serotonin and depression
involving tens of thousands of people
one of the findings was that research
comparing levels of serotonin and its
breakdown products in the blood or brain
fluids did not discover any difference
between people diagnosed with depression
and healthy people the authors also
looked at studies where serotonin levels
were artificially lowered in hundreds of
people and concluded that lowering
serotonin in this way did not produce
depression in hundreds of healthy
volunteers
other studies looked at the effects of
stressful life events and found that the
more stressful life events a person has
experienced the more likely they were to
be depressed showing the importance of
external events
who would have thought
apparently external events you know the
things that happened to us in our lives
the events that we're a part of the
things that we suffer from the things
that we encounter like all of that your
everyday life
these have a deep and lasting effect on
our moods and our emotions and our
mental states
now of course even with this study or
rather without this study debunking the
chemical imbalance theory which was
never really a theory actually but more
of an unproven and arbitrary guess
but before the study was was even
published it was already obvious
that the chemical imbalance idea made no
sense for one thing in order to diagnose
an imbalance we must first have some
idea
of what the correct balance is supposed
to be and yet none i would wager to say
none of the 90 percent of the public who
believes in the chemical imbalance can
articulately explain what sort of
balance we're supposed to have on our
brains oh there's a chemical imbalance
oh really what so what's the
what's what is our balance supposed to
be exactly what's like the ideal balance
well i don't know i just know that it's
imbalance
and even if we did know what sort of
balance we're supposed to have how
exactly do they diagnose the imbalance i
mean do they diagnose it at all
out of all the millions of people
prescribed antidepressants were any of
them given a brain scan or a blood test
or any other sort of physical medical
test to confirm that this imbalance
existed before it was treated
like these are drugs that are supposed
to treat a physical problem did they
ever do anything to confirm the
existence of the physical problem inside
the individual before giving them the
drugs for it
no
never
well that's odd
if depression is simply biochemical in
origin then why isn't it diagnosed on a
biochemical basis
if it's a simple physical ailment why
isn't it confirmed physically
before being treated as if it's simply
physical
these are the kinds of questions we
could have been asking all along but
hardly anyone ever did
i want to read one last part of this
report because it's important it says
according to the research there is also
evidence from other studies that
antidepressants may actually induce
induce low serotonin in the long term
it may actually create the problem it's
supposed to fix
quote our view is that patients should
not be told that oppression is caused by
low serotonin or by chemical imbalance
they should not be led to believe that
antidepressants work by targeting these
unproven abnormalities quote we do not
understand we do not understand what
antidepressants are doing to the brain
exactly and giving people this sort of
misinformation prevents them from making
an informed decision about whether to
take antidepressants or not
they don't understand exactly what these
drugs are doing to the body
but they prescribe them anyway that's
another thing that i've been saying for
years
the people giving these drugs out don't
actually know exactly what they do
because the brain the human brain's a
complicated place
you know
putting people on drugs putting things
into people's bodies without really
knowing what's what it's going to do
there seems to be a lot of that sort of
thing going around these days
a lot of it
and this sort of half-blind approach is
particularly terrifying as it relates to
the brain
because the brain again is still a
mystery to us in many ways and yet drug
companies are tinkering with it messing
with our minds without really knowing
whether what they're doing will work or
or how it's working if it does work or
what the long-term or even short-term
effects will be
one of the side effects of of many
psychiatric drugs is suicidal thoughts
which is morbidly ironic because again
that's the problem that they're supposed
to help treat and yet they can cause
that problem apparently so
these are drugs which according to the
companies that produce them may cause
you to think certain thoughts they may
put thoughts into your head
self-destructive dangerous thoughts
that fact alone should give us pause
does this mean that there is no physical
aspect of depression of course not i
mean we're physical beings our brains
are physical
there's going to be a significant
physical element to the problem i mean
to any problem that we suffer from
including mental problems by definition
but it's also multifaceted and
complicated depression is a feeling of
emptiness despair hopelessness
meaninglessness
if a person is feeling that way it's
almost always impossible to start to
discern one simple cause that's what the
drug companies sell
one simple cause but it's never that
simple
there are internal and external factors
all tracing back to the universal human
condition the fact that we are
mortal beings living in a world of
constant pain and suffering and death
and misery with lots of aimlessness and
boredom in between
yeah the depressed person is is not
crazy or sick
because they recognize this fact about
life
in fact here's here's the here's the uh
the point that we always miss in this
discussion there are a lot actually of
very good reasons
to feel pretty bad
living as just a human being in the
world world could be a really tough
place
it doesn't mean that we should feel bad
doesn't mean that if someone does feel
bad we should just leave them to their
misery
but the point is that these feelings are
not crazy they're not delusional
there's there's there are reasons for
them
and person whose person is overcome with
these feelings their problem is is um
is that they are not able to
sufficiently cope
with
our condition as human beings in this
world
they're not able to find meaning and
hope and joy in spite of
all the terrible things that come with
being a human being in the world
the way to treat the depression is to
help them cope which will involve
everything from better lifestyle choices
to diet and exercise getting outside on
a sunny day and taking a walk like
things like that even really really
simple things it's not the be all and
all but things like that
in some cases there may still be need
for for drugs temporarily but they're
going to be a band-aid not a cure
you can't cure despair with a pill
despite what the drug companies have
told us
and the drug companies have told us a
lot of lies they have
especially recently
and it's quite a statement but this
might be the biggest one yet
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right well speaking of drugs not
doing the job
president biden here's the breaking news
president biden has tested positive for
covet 19.
uh this is the statement from press
secretary karen gene pair
says this morning president biden tested
positive for covet 19 he's fully
vaccinated and twice boosted and
experiencing very mild symptoms he's
begun taking pax lovid consistent with
cdc guidelines he will isolate at the
white house and will continue to carry
out all of his duties fully during that
term he has been in contact with members
of the white house staff by phone this
morning will participate in his planned
meetings of the white house this morning
via phone and zoom from the residence
um consistent fro with white house
protocol for positive coverage cases
which goes above and beyond cdc guidance
he will continue to work in isolation
until he tests negative once he tests
negative he will return to in-person
work
um and he only works for three four
hours a day so you know that's the good
news i guess light workload
so this is uh so
joe biden has
you know got got fully vaccinated so he
got the first shot then got the second
shot
then got the booster shot
and then got another booster shot
and he still got
covered and so now he's taking a pill
made by
the same companies that produced
the shot that didn't stop him from
getting sick
pretty amazing
and this happens
you know if we can recall
only about um a year after joe biden
claimed at a town hall
it was almost one year ago exactly i
think
that joe biden said
that you're not going to get covered if
you get the vaccination let's go back
and listen to that again
there you're okay you're not going to
you're not going to get covet if you
have these vaccinations yeah
that's what he claimed
you're not going to get uh coveted if
you get the vaccination but that's
that's something that we we're just
we've erased from our memory there are
many things related to cova that we're
supposed to erase for our memory and one
of them is that we were told in the
early going
that if you get the shots you will not
get code
and then there was this enormous
shifting of the goal post when it when
it turned out that whether you get the
shot or not you're still going to get
sick from covet
and we're just going to pretend that
none of that was ever said oh we never
said that just it just makes your
symptoms more mild
unfalsifiable by the way that's the
great thing about that
somebody is
has has the vaccine has all the boosters
they get sick anyway and then you can
just you could just uh declare that well
they'd be so much more sick if they
didn't have the vaccine well how do you
know that i mean how do you know what
would have happened in this other
theoretical universe where they never
got vaccinated
you don't really know that
but you can declare it
another common theme here especially
where the drug companies are concerned
uh things that they can't really know
and don't know but they'll just say it
anyway
never held accountable for it
and uh i mean just think
it's not to belabor the point but
this is four shots that he got in the
span of what 18 months
four shots to protect against this virus
and he still got it
and that's on top of all the other
preventative measures that they do for
the president still got it
now the timing here is um
interesting and also concerning because
it was just yesterday
that uh that
biden and cancer were trending today on
twitter biden has coveted is uh trending
yesterday was biden has cancer because
during a speech he seemed to
say that he has he seemed to announce
that he has cancer let's go back and
watch it this is from yesterday
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation
that's why i and many other people i
grew up with have cancer uh what
is
we've never really gotten a
clarification for the white house on
this does the president have cancer is
that something we should probably know
does he give cancer and covet now
well that's not a good combination and
he's elderly
shouldn't we know these things
this is how bad it's gotten that um
you know the president said the
president united states said yesterday
that he has cancer that is what he said
and
but we're all kind of
uh assuring ourselves that he doesn't
really have cancer he just has dementia
so he says stuff like this
so either he has either this is either
him making that statement is either due
to the fact that he really does have
cancer or oh no it's just dementia
flaring up again
not a good situation to be in
as a country and this is the guy leading
things
all right let's move to this this is
from the daily wire iconic music venue
first avenue cave to backlash on
thursday canceling comedian dave
chappelle's show hours before his
performance was slated to start the
venue located in minnesota has
reportedly been receiving backlash for
planning to host chappelle the comedian
liens left but has refused to play the
politically correct game with his
material specifically when it comes to
radical gender theory first avenue
posted on social media on thursday
evening
we hear you the dave chappelle show
tonight at first avenue has been
canceled and is moving to the varsity
theater we know we must hold ourselves
to the highest standards and we know we
let you down we are not just a black box
with people in it and we understand that
first avenue is not just a room but
meaningful beyond our walls the first
avenue team and you have worked hard to
make our venues the safest spaces in the
country and we will continue with that
measured message we believe in diverse
voices and the freedom of artistic
expression but in honoring that we lost
sight of the impact this would have we
know that there are some who will not
agree with this decision
you are all welcome to send feedback
this is always kind of uh mind-boggling
this sort of thing because
they got backlash for hosting dave
chappelle and immediately caved it's not
like they put up a fight okay
uh they didn't put up any fight at all
they caved right away that's not the
mind-boggling thing that's what we
expect
the the somewhat confusing thing is that
well you must have known
that this backlash would come
if you're even
slightly clued in
if you haven't been living in a cave
somewhere
then then you would know that it's going
to be quote unquote controversial to
have to host dave chappelle at your
venue shouldn't be controversial
but we live in an insane society and so
it is and so you you obviously knew that
going in so
weren't you didn't you kind of batten
down the hatches weren't you prepared
girding your loins ready for ready for
battle
so you you you make this decision to do
something that you know is going to
upset people that part is great i'm all
in favor of that
doing something even though it's going
to upset the peanut gallery and they're
going to be crying about it fine i'm on
board for that 100
and you go in with your eyes open but
then immediately as the backlash comes
the backlash you knew was coming when it
does come you give up right
away and the thing about dave chappelle
that i think we lose sight of is that
you know chappelle i i appreciate
most of what he says on the topic of of
gender
um
which is actually sex you know what most
of what he says on the topic of
biological sex i appreciate i agree with
most of it
but dave chappelle is actually far less
offensive than he's ever been
it may shock uh kids today but go back
and watch
the chappelle show on comedy central
back in you know back when it was i
think first aired almost 20 years ago
now
early 2000s
you take any any single skit from that
show
far more provocative than anything he
said at any point over the last like
eight or nine years
and so he actually has you know he he
gets credit for standing up
against the mob and i give him credit
for that too but he actually has
softened quite a bit and i don't know if
that's just
old age or what or or if he's trying to
appease the mob a little bit but i'm not
sure what it is but he has softened his
approach quite a bit and he's not nearly
as controversial as he used to be
and even when he talks about
gender the things that he says about it
are
there they're not anywhere close to what
you're gonna hear on this show for
example he doesn't go anywhere near that
and he does often make a point of saying
well i don't judge any trans people and
i respect their identity he says all
that kind of stuff and then he gets into
the
into the rest of it
so it's it is a it's a sad day um
not just when
you know comedians are getting kicked
out of venues for committing the crime
of telling jokes
but when when current day dave chappelle
is the most controversial comedian
on the national stage that is a
very sad statement
all right alexandria ocasio-cortez
here's an actual funny joke this i think
is a funnier joke than uh than really
anything dave chappelle's actually said
over the last several years uh alexandra
casa cortez went over yesterday she
along with other democrats um showed up
at this protest pageant
intentionally got arrested
because they were sitting in the street
it was a pro-abortion thing they were
sitting in the middle of the street they
were warned three times you got to get
up they didn't so they were arrested
only arrested in the in the technical
sense if they were even arrested in the
technical sense which i'm not sure that
they actually i'm not sure if what
happened to them qualifies as being
arrested technically or not but they
were momentarily briefly detained by
police officers uh they were not sent to
jail they weren't charged with any with
anything really and they were not cuffed
and yet alexandra casa cortez pretended
to be handcuffed
and we played the the footage for
yesterday she wasn't the only one was
also ilhan omar
hands behind the back
being escorted by police
uh that's not a way that people normally
walk
and so she was clearly pretending to be
handcuffed
we were waiting for her to finally
defend herself against the charge that
she was pretending to be handcuffed and
she has and she hasn't disappointed so
she has offered kind of two excuses and
the first is um this on instagram
where she says that the claim that she
was pretending to be handcuffed is a
conspiracy theory listen
republican's favorite hobby is to make
conspiracy theories out of everything to
distract you and keep you from talking
about what's actually important which is
the fact that they are trying to take
away your right to bodily autonomy if i
was faking that why would i
intentionally fist pump somebody
yeah if you were well can i i'd love to
answer that question aoc thank you for
asking it's a great question
if you were faking having handcuffs
and yet you put the fist up anyway why
would you do that well because you're
very stupid
that's why you would do it because
you're a stupid person
but it's not a conspiracy we're not
we're not alleging that you conspired
with anyone to pretend to be handcuffed
you you totally did that on your own
well we've we fully know that
we're not we're not saying that this was
some grand conspiracy between you and
the police this is just you on your own
doing what you do best and you still
don't do that well
which is performing
one thing one thing that helps you
clarify things is when you understand
and i'm not the first person to point
this out but it's a it's an important
insight anyway
uh that
a great number of politicians especially
the ones on the national stage the ones
you know uh the ones in dc
they wanted to be actors most of them
and they ended up as politicians because
either they were too ugly to be actors
or they didn't have the talent
so this is this is like a fallback
option for them
and once you come to understand that
some of this stuff begins to make sense
she also responded to the charge on
twitter and she was responding to a
tweet from nancy mace who most recently
we saw she's the republican uh
congresswoman who voted along with the
democrats to have the federal government
redefine marriage nationwide so that's
the kind of conservative she is but she
accused aoc of of performance art and
faking the handcuffs and aoc said
no faking here putting your hands behind
your back is a best practice while
detained handcuffed or not
to avoid escalating charges like
resisting arrest but given how you lied
about a fellow rape survivor for points
as you put it to me i don't expect much
else from you putting your hands behind
your back is best practice when dealing
with police first of all since when does
aoc care about the best practices when
dealing with police and second i can
tell you right now that is most
definitely not best practice that is
quite literally the opposite of best
practices when you're dealing with
police which is why
you never hear a police officer shout to
like a bad guy
come out with your hands behind your
back
hey hey put your hands up where i can't
see them yeah right right behind your
back right now right next to your to
your waistband where people usually keep
guns right there yep keep them right
there
i don't want to see your hands
that's not what police officers say
you put your hands behind your back if
they're going to cuff you
but if they're not going to cuff you
then what they want is your hands out
and up they want they want your hands
visible they want they want your hands
away from your waistband that's where
they want your hands
best practices
still walk with your hands behind your
back
all right yeah yeah well you know what
actual best practice is put your hands
in your pockets when dealing with the
cops
cops have their guns drawn on your best
practice put your hand right in your
pocket just kidding please do not do
that
um
all right i want to play this for you
here's a teacher
boasting about making her students i
think this is a her can't be sure but
making her students use pronouns i want
you to listen to what she says i know
i'm probably going to get a lot for this
but i don't really care who cares
we're doing
summer programming and this year i vowed
to make a really strong effort to figure
out how my students want to be
acknowledged
as far as their pronouns so naturally
i'm leading by example right i've got my
name
she her that's how i identify
easy simple so they know that they would
call me miss kramer instead of you know
mister or whatever because you know the
hair they're still stigma whatever on
our first assignment i asked them to put
their preferred pronouns on their papers
and not one kid protested not one kid
they were all
super comfortable and super down with it
but look at this i'm covering their name
but look at that
i'm okay being called they them she hurt
or he him
they're totally down for that i can't
help but feel like that kid now feels
safe
and comfortable being who they are
you have to you have to just think about
how creepy it is uh to hear and we hear
this we hear this this excuse from the
groomer so often
um but when they say oh it's okay
because the kid the kids are okay with
it
when we do this to the kids they're okay
with it so it's so we can do it
yeah that's that's
certainly not the first time we hear
that from from that excuse from groomers
and child predators
that's like the classic
excuse
from creeps like that
oh not one kid protested
well of course they didn't of course
they didn't protest
number one they're kids
so
they're just gonna accept whatever you
tell them
um and and even if they don't i mean
they might ask questions they might the
kids have their kids certainly are
capable of skepticism
uh and any parent knows the kids will
ask they certainly will ask questions
but here's what a kid's not gonna do
a kid is not going to most of the time
question the underlying
fundamental
premise of something
so they're usually what a kids
especially if they're if they're getting
being told something from authority
figure
they're going to accept the the premise
right so
the example that i always use is like
what's one of the most fantastical if
you have kids that are listening right
now cover their ears
what's one of the most fantastical
things that adults will tell kids is
that santa claus exists and kids will
they'll have a lot of questions about
santa claus right they'll ask a lot of
questions a lot of really really
specific questions and pretty good
questions but what they won't do at
least until they get older is question
the whole underlying claim that there is
a santa claus to begin with that part
they'll accept
and then it's some of the
the um
kind of claims that go along with that
that the last question is about
so they're looking at the branches of
the tree but they're not going after the
roots that's not what kids do
and they shouldn't have to they should
be able to trust the authority figures
in their lives especially an authority
figure who's in the position of
educating them
so that's one reason why they why
they're going to go along
they're totally cool the kids are
totally cool with it yeah that's one
reason the other reason is that
even the kids who have learned to be
more skeptical about the underlying
claim they also know that they're in an
environment where they cannot voice that
skepticism for fear of social
ostracization or from actual uh
punishments and penalties from the
administration at the school
so you've got a metaphorical gun to
their heads
saying this is the way now and if you
don't like it then you're a bigot and
that's the worst thing you could
possibly do you can be socially
ostracized and then all the kids just go
along with you say look at that they
went along with it
i mean you might as well go up to
someone and put a gun to their head and
ask for all the money all the money in
their wallet and then they give it to
you and then they say look they were
willing to give me their money yeah i
wasn't stealing from them at all
actually they gave it to me
all right um a few other things i want
to get to we'll try to
go through some of these uh quickly get
as much get to as much as we can
here is more environmental hysteria
which has been the theme of the of the
month as the temperatures get hotter and
so we start worrying about global
warming this is a report from theday.com
it says the global extinction crisis
underway may be more intense than
previously thought as humans continue to
tear up land over use certain resources
and heat up the planet new research led
by the university of minnesota indicates
nearly one in three species of all kinds
30 percent face global extinction or
have been driven to extinction since the
year 1500 according to the new survey
published in the journal frontiers in
ecology and environment
that's significantly higher than
prevailing global estimates and the
findings surprised lead author forrest
isbell he said one of the reasons is
that it takes more insects and other
lesser studied species groups into
account so
and there were other headlines about
this the global extinction crisis so you
can add that to all of the
environmental cataclysms and armageddons
that we face another one and they're all
linked together and and later on in the
same report he links this into uh
climate change and everything else but
um
one another one is is the so-called
extinction crisis
but as we just talked about with kids
they don't they never question the
underlying premise
kids don't do that as adults we should
and even on something like this
it's always heresy to do it of course to
question the the premise any time
the left tells you anything the question
is heresy
especially when it's something like this
it's just it's like well they're saying
it's a global extinction crisis
the only appropriate response is to
throw up your hands and scream and cry
that's all you're supposed to do if you
do anything about that then you're a
horrible
sociopath who doesn't care about all
these innocent species
well the only thing that i will note
and i'm not saying that there isn't
necessarily some sort of extinction
crisis going on
i'm not saying there isn't
i'm saying i need more evidence of it
and i'm not just going to accept it
because you claim
because here's something else that i
know which is that um 99.9
of all species that have ever lived on
earth
are currently extinct
and the vast majority went extinct
before human civilization
existed so millions and millions of
species came and went
long before the egyptians
even built the pyramids
so that's something that i know
which means that
species go extinct you know this is this
is something that naturally happens
species go extinct
and so even if we didn't have
industrialized society
if uh we talk about from the year 1500
to now that's that so many species went
extinct well even if human beings
weren't on earth
a certain at least large percentage of
those species would have went extinct
anyway
so what we need to know is without
humans how many would have gone extinct
and then we know how many we can blame
on ourselves
and once we have that information i'm
not sure what exactly we do with it
i guess we just walk through the street
you know whipping ourselves and crying
maya culpa
that's what we're supposed to do
um
let's see one other thing to know this
is from
cnsnews.com it says a new poll um
this is a by the way a new poll that
that some christians have been
trumpeting as kind of a success story
but i don't know if i see it that way so
it's a new poll of likely catholic
voters found that 82 percent of
catholics support ending abortion
outright or imposing various regulations
to limit it also a majority of catholics
oppose pro-transgender policy in regard
to their children's sports teams and
school bathrooms further a majority of
catholics say they disapprove of
president joe biden's job as president
likely catholic voters were more aligned
when it came to transgender ideology in
school 67 percent said they opposed
biological boys who identify as female
using the girls schools
bathrooms and locker rooms also 67 said
they opposed biological boys competing
against girls on school sports 33
percent said policies in their uh
children's school related to gender
identity made them consider alternative
education also 63 of catholics believe
gender is created by god 56 say trans
ideology conflicts with church teaching
i don't know i
some people are seeing this these as
encouraging numbers because it's a
majority
but i hate to be the guy always pointing
to the
dark cloud within the silver lining but
once again i must do that
only only 63 of catholics believe that
quote gender is created by god
and we have to add the stipulation there
that of course you know in a way gender
was not created by god because gender is
a you know as a category is something
that human beings made up sex was
created by god but in the poll that's
what they meant they're just conflating
the two
so 63 of catholics but only 63 percent
say that uh that sex is created by god
and only a slim majority 56 say that
trans ideology conflicts with church
teaching
this would be if these were the numbers
like nationwide cultural
uh culture-wide if these were the
numbers
then i would say that we're trending in
the right direction
but within the church uh no this is a
unfortunately very bad sign
all right let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
jimmy c says i'd love to see and i
prefer not to play the preferred pronoun
game t-shirt
um that's a little wordy
maybe something like a different idea
more simple would be something like
nobody cares about your pronouns we put
that on a t-shirt something like that
we'll work we'll workshop it we'll work
with it
um david s says matt you should make
more documentaries similar to what is a
woman such as what is marriage what is a
person and what is truth i give these
kind of suggestions all the time
and they're good suggestions but what i
would also say is you know maybe maybe
one day we do something like that but
but also
um someone else can pick up the mantle
on some of these
you know i'd love i'd love to see just
like
in the movie what as a woman
we
cover a lot of ground
and you could circle back and take any
one of these avenues that we just sort
of touched on and do a whole movie about
it
the origins of gender theory that's five
minutes in the movie you go back into a
whole movie about it maybe maybe that's
something we end up doing but uh i would
also love to see other people do that
uh
metfreak 101 says
my five-year-old nephew is allowed to
play vr all day long which i could not
disagree with more i don't think we
really know the damage things like that
could do to a young mind uh yeah to a
five-year-old well well i'll disagree
with you on one thing we do know
some of the damage anyway
there has been research on this now it's
it's true that we can't we can't know
the full extent of it
there are a lot of things that are
happening to kids right now that are
relatively unprecedented and so we can't
know the full extent we can't know
for sure
um how this is all going to manifest
itself 20 or 30 years down the line
but we know enough to say that having
your kid using any screen
at the age of five
for long periods of the day every day is
a really bad idea
and to have that screen right up against
his eyes and wearing a headset blocking
out the whole rest of the world
absorbed in this virtual reality fantasy
world yeah not not good
i mean at the age of five
at the uh
your kid is this is why it frustrates me
so much he's he's a five right he's a
five-year-old boy
five-year-old boys are so easy to keep
entertained
you don't need all the fancy gadgets you
don't need that
you you can
one of the most classic examples
everybody knows you an empty box
you give a five-year-old boy an empty
box that is a large empty box that is
hours of entertainment
or like a a stick
mike both of my boys are older than that
i mean my oldest boy is nine years old
and can still be
vastly entertained by a stick
i don't know all the things that he you
know pretending it's a sword doing all
whatever
that's uh and the thing is if you have a
five-year-old boy who is not able to
entertain themselves with a box or a
stick or some other just random object
who can't go run outside and have fun
then
that's a sign that
he's already absorbed too much of the
screen time and become dependent on it
so now i think the the
this calls for some cold turkey take it
away force him to go out
and use his imagination to have fun
it's for his own good
let's see cody says i agree with a lot
of what matt has to say but he's
severely out of touch with americans
perspective of gay marriage this could
be a unifying issue and you continue to
widen the gap between americans
well why would you think that i give the
slightest damn about americans
perspective
that's i don't care yeah i'm i'm fully
aware cody
that when it comes to the marriage issue
i am in the minority fully aware of that
i know that
it means that means nothing to me i
don't care
it doesn't
the truth doesn't become not the truth
anymore
because fewer people are saying it
and something that's untrue doesn't
become true just because more people are
saying it
okay the truth is not decided
democratically
is not a democratic pursuit it just is
right
you could have a a a genocide and wipe
out everyone who is proclaiming a
certain truth
which we may be we may eventually reach
that point in our society and now
there's nobody left who's saying it but
it's still true
every single person on earth could
ignore it and deny it it's still true
so i'm not convinced by numbers
when it comes to fundamental moral
issues
or scientific issues or frankly any
issue any kind of issue i'm not
convinced by numbers um i can't i am
convinced by arguments if they're good
and so i would say to you what i said it
during the show yesterday
which is that you know for thousands of
years for millennia we had a certain
idea of what marriage is
it is an in-principle pro-creative union
serves as the foundation of a nuclear
family like that's what marriage is
that's the function that it served
and then people like you came along
right
and said it's not that anymore and as
you point out there are a lot of people
saying it's not that anymore millions of
them so i'm way outnumbered fine
well as i'm surrounded outnumbered by
this crowd of people screaming at me can
anyone in that crowd tell me what
marriage is now why it should no longer
be what it was before and what it is now
if it's not that
if you can't explain that then uh then i
it doesn't
if you're babbling nonsense it doesn't
matter how many of you are babbling it's
still nonsense
well as you're all aware no one can
define the word woman as of about five
minutes ago the people in my documentary
what is woman legislators supreme court
appointees you name it as we've already
discussed merriam-webster redefined
female in the hopes that they could
stuff it down the memory hole without
anybody noticing and frankly this is the
most attention a dictionary is getting
in the history of etymology with all
that in mind we've decided to enlist the
help of a team of biologists to create a
garment
in a lab it's the first time we've done
this
and that was what finally gave rise to
the definition of woman t-shirt and it
is here to educate all of those confused
individuals by emblazoning your chest
with the proper non-circular definition
of the word woman again we we did
consult with biologists i think we got
this one right head over to uh my swag
check dailywire.com shop to purchase
this shirt and see all the other amazing
products that my swag shack has to offer
today it'll never not be cringy saying
swag shock we have to stop doing that we
really do also by the way reading
classic books uh will make you smart but
watching ben shapiro discuss classic
books will make you even smarter so do
the smart thing and tune in to this
month's episode of ben shapiro's book
club tonight at 8 p.m eastern you'll
meet up with ben in israel as he
explores the historical novel an
international bestseller exodus set
amidst the jewish people's displacement
from a hostile post-war europe exodus is
a story of an american nurse and is an
israeli freedom fighter and the rebirth
of a nation that had been dispersed for
2 000 years it's a triumphant piece of
literature and with ben's always
excellent analysis being brought to you
from the deeply historic and visually
stunning jerusalem tonight's book club
is a can't miss to watch ben shapiro's
book club you need to be an all-access
member so go to dailywireplus.com to
sign up for upgrade today and get 35 off
your membership that's
dailywireplus.com then join ben in the
holy land tonight at 8pm to discuss the
book exodus now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well up until today my favorite story
out of the leftist dystopia of portland
happened a few years ago as reported by
andy noah at the time a professional
equity activist named lillian complained
about the racism she experienced at a
bakery called back to eden bakery and
lillian if you remember this story she
said that she had been refused service
by the two employees on staff and the
only logical explanation for this
refusal of course was that the employees
were vicious out in the open anti-black
races who just so happened to work in
downtown portland
after all why else would anyone
refuse service to a black woman i mean
why else would these two employees
actually tell the woman to leave without
allowing her to purchase any baked goods
that's what they said to her they said
leave
the owner of the bakery couldn't imagine
any other reason so she immediately
fired both of the transgressors threw
them under the bus publicly
and she also promised to hire black
women and members of the quote lgbtq poc
community to replace the two clansmen
that she had on her staff
further the the owner pledged to donate
10 percent of their sales to a charity
that bails criminals out of jail and all
of this was done but of course it was
not nearly enough to assuage the hurt
and pain and anguish suffered by lillian
but it was a start
anyway oh um one note that might be
relevant here lillian came to the bakery
after it was closed
so she walked in six minutes after
closing and demanded to be served and
they refused on the basis that they were
no longer open
but that excuse wouldn't fly the bakery
should have checked with lillian
personally before deciding to close that
evening indeed they should have pulled
every black woman in the city
to see when they should close and open
and if any black woman desires a muffin
at any time of day or night
and is not able to procure it
immediately for low cost or no cost
then she is the victim of racism and
whatever bakery is nearest to her while
she is suffering this muffin deprivation
is guilty of committing a hate crime
against her
this just makes sense
i mean the bakery agreed that it made
sense
overall it was a great portland story my
favorite until this week anyway
lives of tick tock on her site libs of
tick tock dot com
has a story i think even better than a
bakery being accused of racism for not
serving a black woman after they already
closed
apparently uh this is what the story is
after after much fanfare and celebration
a lesbian bar opened this month in
portland called doc marie's and there
had surprisingly not been a lesbian bar
in portland so this was seen as a
significant and important event
an opening day was a huge success lines
around the block waiting to get in
a week later the place was closed
and the reason
is pretty hilarious reading now from the
report it says doc marie's is a lesbian
bar that opened on july 1st of this year
with the hope of bringing more
inclusivity to the city of portland
just one week after their grand opening
they were forced to shut down because of
complaints the bar was not a safe space
the crowd on opening day was huge one
woman said that the line for entry on
moping day was wrapped around the block
with literally 200 lesbians waiting to
get in but the excitement about a new
progressive hangout dissipated quickly
within days doc maurice found itself on
the receiving end of accusations of not
being inclusive enough for trans people
and people of color despite mass
mandates being lifted in portland
patrons accused the bar of not
implementing enough coveted safety
measures patrons also claim that doc
marie's had culturally appropriate
appropriative art on the walls
that's just some of it it gets worse a
tick-tocker who goes by the handle
danger dallas and identifies herself as
a queer stripper who uses they them
pronouns followed the doc maurice case
closely as closely as you would expect
and provided a thorough outline of some
of the sins the lesbian bar committed in
just a week of being open
let's listen to that
payroll systems that are not paying
people correctly discrepancies in um
salaries dirty water leaking onto the
floor
um and the owner enabling racist
behavior
so the the real reason why doc murray's
is closed is because when the workers
brought these concerns to the ownership
the next day after opening day the
ownership did not meet the concerns with
any sort of plan of action and the
unsatisfactory response caused the
managers to quit their jobs immediately
the workers collective goes on to assure
us that protecting black and brown lgbtq
plus folks in building an acti actively
anti-racist space is their top priority
that they are committed to ongoing
racial bias training and will continue
to educate ourselves in order to
actively foster a safe environment while
upholding a zero policy towards racism
so we take from that that the entire
staff made a list of demands
and because those demands were not met
right on the spot
they all quit
a day after the place opened
back to the libs of tick tock report it
says employees of doc marie's created an
instagram page to echo these concerns
they claim that the owners weren't
proactive enough in creating a safe
space and accused the owners of racism
the employees also demanded that the bar
host free opportunities for education
for the community eventually the
employees demanded the owners relinquish
ownership of the bar and hand the
business over to them
this all happened in like a day of being
open i have to remind you the owners
were given a 24-hour deadline to adhere
to the ludicrous demands just five days
after opening the bar announced on july
6 they had to close temporarily in order
to address the cries from the woke mob
for a safe and inclusive space
and now the bar is closed with no
immediate plans to reopen they say only
that they are working on a plan to
become proud and inclusive
meanwhile their employees or former
employees i guess
still insists that the the business they
chose to work for
committed an unforgivable violation
by being a business
they demanded the business should not be
a business at all it should be it should
have no ownership
it should provide free services and its
primary goal should be racial equity
now as a greedy capitalist i would have
thought that a business's primary goal
is to turn a profit
so that it remains in business
but that's just not the way things are
done in portland
and the problem only compounds for doc
marines because
they're closed you know they closed so
as to stop inflicting whatever
unspecified trauma on the black and
trans community
but as the bakery learned a few years
ago
you're also inflicting trauma by being
closed
see this is the trouble with being a
black or trans person in portland
literally no matter what anyone else
does they are always victimizing you
and the bigger problem for being not
black or trans in portland is that
literally no matter what you do you're
always victimizing someone in one of
those groups
now i of course am not at all interested
in
defending the portland lesbian bar from
the woke mob i am interested instead in
standing on the sidelines and uh just
snickering about the whole thing because
it's funny and also in observing and
studying this self-cannibalizing
victimhood orgy
to see what we can learn from it and as
far as i can tell the big and also kind
of encouraging takeaway
is that leftism is inherently weak and
vulnerable
it has institutional power and so it
controls the culture but considered on
its own
we see that it's prone to dissension
mutiny paralysis
this is just one example of the left
eating itself every day provides new
ones
and this happens because leftism is a
fundamentally self-focused self-obsessed
ideology it discourages any real unity
any real rallying around a central cause
because everyone's central cause is
themselves all alliances are formed only
temporarily for as long as each person
individually feels served by it
nobody is looking out towards anything
transcendent anything beyond themselves
it's hard for them to march in the same
direction together for very long because
they're all staring not ahead but back
into themselves
into their egos
up their own asses basically
the only universal code they recognize
is the ever fluctuating ever changing
ever more complicated victimhood
hierarchy a system that breeds
competition as each group views for
ultimate victim status
and each individual within each group
competes not only with the other groups
but with members of their own group
intersectional splinter factions are
constantly formed as people look to
marginalize themselves more and more
because in their inverted upside down
world to be on the margins is to be in
power
it is fortunate for the left tragic for
the rest of us that this final plunge
into self-defeating self-cannibalizing
madness happened after they'd already
gained control of every institution if
it had happened before they never would
have had this success
this is what creates the ironic
situation where the far left runs
the most powerful cultural institutions
in the country
but they can't even manage to keep a
lesbian bar in portland open for more
than a week
and still even with their institutional
power
this madness makes them vulnerable it
makes them beatable
and sometimes
it even makes them very funny to watch
and so though i am not the one who
decided to cancel them that is
nonetheless why doc marie's the lesbian
bar in portland
is today cancelled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt well show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
joe biden announces that he has cancer a
new study raises major alarm about the
mrna fauchy ouchy covid shots and pbs
tries to make you eat the bugs check it
out on the michael knowles show